[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
nine perfect strangers episode five
sweet surrender this is directed by
jonathan levine like every episode is
but this is solely written by the
showrunner david e kelly who i'm always
a fan of his writing so i was excited to
see how this one turns out and if you
look at this episode as a whole when
you're watching it it can feel slow a
little bit tedious but i'm hoping that
it's one of those episodes that you look
back at it and it looks great because
there's a lot of things working here
there might be frustrations at the point
of the season we're in that we're
getting this but what this episode
really does is it's a focus on
remembering that everybody is at a
higher dosage here so like the title
sweet surrender everyone's kind of
surrendering their egos they're letting
go now and everyone's being nice to each
other and what this episode does really
well is it makes all these close
relationships and bonds happen with so
many characters here and what i'm hoping
is that if you're frustrated with this
episode that you're going to end up
loving this episode because hopefully
the next episode stuff starts to hit the
fan and we get payoff for what all this
character building relationship building
this episode happens so i think we're
going to look back at this episode and
love it if we look at the whole season
it might be frustrating on its own but
i'm gonna review it as it is on its own
and how well it does relationship
building and character payoffs and
character building so we'll start with
the opening scene where we learn through
masha in this pool thinking about
flashbacks and we get introduced to this
relationship she has more with delilah
what happened what went on that there's
this trauma for delilah she knows about
because somebody died at the resort and
it clearly was someone under delilah's
care so there's guilt there and
mashinosis and feels guilty herself that
she didn't pay enough attention to what
delilah was going through at that moment
now do we know if masha really cares
about delilah's feelings at a moment or
she just checking her bases with maybe
why delilah's been acting off we don't
really know yet but i'm gonna go with
the latter but we also see again this
flashback of when she got shot masha and
it's revealed that the man who shot her
has this white eyeball so something
mysterious going on there so it's giving
you a little bit more breadcrumbs to
that central mystery of the show so we
get this first scene here with zoe
played by the brilliant grace van patten
who really has a standout episode here
and i hope this show finally gives her a
due she's been an up-and-coming actress
for a while now who's very talented and
i think this will give the exposure she
needs for her career to kind of set off
but we see that she's hallucinating her
dead brother zack this confirms seeing
who zack is that this is the same person
that her father napoleon has envisioned
in his flashbacks that yes that is his
son who's sitting at the tree so that's
interesting but he's saying you know
it's first happy birthday but he's like
but it's not your fault so it's
addressing the guilt that zoe feels
about her brother's death and then it
confirms that she was lying to lars and
that they were absolutely close because
he's like why aren't you telling people
we were close so there's a really good
line here she's like i'm so lonely
didn't know what it felt like to be
lonely because i always had you i
thought this was really actually
effective and powerful and worked and
kind of made us get closer to zoe and
sticking on that family you know i
actually did like the scene a lot again
michael shannon's just crushing it so
seeing him just perform his tail off is
also a treat and him singing grease and
dancing was great but what's important
about that is that it's cutting between
these cocktails and smoothies being made
that are really on high drugs and like i
said upping the dosage and it's cutting
between that because it's showing you
the strange behavior that's happening
now we get this interesting scene that i
also thought was very effective where
everyone's the next morning at breakfast
and they're talking about vivid dreams
they're having while also francis comes
in really heavy tripping here but this
dream that lars talks about that he had
about having a child and tony being the
one who was close to him that situation
sets up really two good payoffs for lars
character in tony's character which
we'll get to but what i really like how
they shot the scene was just moving you
into francis's deep tripping without
showing you her actually pass out first
so it did that trickery you knew at the
point where this guy paul that she's had
all these problems with that when he was
being hostile towards her work okay then
you knew this was some kind of
hallucination she was having but it's
confirming the self-hate she has towards
herself more of believing she's a hack
and a phony and also it kind of speaking
to herself that she believes maybe paul
left her part of this that he thought
she was a hack and talentless but that
also will get its payoff with her
relationship with tony which we're gonna
get to and it was important moment just
even napoleon talking about the song he
was singing that beatles song something
and that this would trigger carmel and
she stabs a fork at the table so even
all their happiness and all these drugs
you get these side effects of like crazy
rage and caramel this is the first
trigger again about her ex relationship
and that was the wedding song and that
will come through also later on with her
scene with lars which we're gonna get to
as well but when i'm talking about the
presentation the scene i like that when
we get back and the reveal that francis
did pass out and her face comes up
through the oatmeal i thought that was
pretty funny but it also has this cool
fish eye effect on the lens and i think
that actually really worked because it
shot the scene very tight and really
making you feel like everyone else was
on this high dose of drugs at this point
but we'll get a scene after this where
tony comforts francis here and says she
is a good writer even though he's only
read a snippet and this is really big
and it's showing you that bond get
tighter and tighter and from where i saw
the first year because i said this
wasn't my favorite you know relationship
of the show it's just gotten stronger
and stronger and becoming my favorite
now and they'll have a great scene later
on too which we're gonna get to like i
always keep saying we're gonna get to
it's gonna be my new tagline so there's
a big scene with masha and delilah here
and what's important about it is that
masha's checking in here on delilah
number one because one she heard about
her saying f off to tony which she can't
be doing as a worker masha knows that so
it's also telling her that she's
checking on to see if she's taking her
dosage like she brought up last episode
so she can control delilah and her
behavior and she's also gonna hint at
like delilah says you think i'm the one
sending you death threats so mash is
really checking in all these marks here
for delilah but there's a great twist
here which i really like which makes
this delilah yao masha love triangle so
much more interesting is that delilah
and masha kiss and you know it's
interesting because she's like masha yao
can never know and she's like he'll
never know so this really turns this all
on its head here which i like and it
will add a complication that's necessary
because it's gonna take away any
doubters like well why wouldn't you know
delilah the voice of reason through the
show just take down masha and this whole
thing going on it's because it's
complicated because she has clearly
feelings for masha so i like that it
adds more to this story and
justification for while delilah's acting
the way she is and great setups again we
talked about how zoe felt lonely now
this scene with her and laura's their
best scene together where lars opens up
about how he had that dream because he
thinks this world is a tough place for a
kid that's why he didn't want to have a
kid and that's why he's thinking about
that where his lover did want a kid and
she gets out of him how it was tough his
childhood and that's why he'd have that
view and that he was bullied because he
was gay that his dad wasn't accepting of
him and that he feels like his dad left
his mom because he was gay so it's
really good acting by luke evans here
but it gets that payoff with zoey where
she's opening up to him about seeing her
brother not telling her parents about
this he said he should but he's like you
shouldn't be alone with this she said
i'm not alone which was a great scene
between these two a nice moment and
again pays off to her loneliness she
talked about and she feels that bond
with lars this stranger now when
napoleon is convincing heather the jump
i thought maybe this scene wasn't
totally necessary that it doesn't really
advance the relationships of napoleon
and heather we kind of already see
they've been bonding now and it didn't
really advance the plot much but what it
did add was an interesting point of view
shot from when they jump off the cliff
it's like when masha jumped off the
cliff and it's like a point of view of
someone watching them so i think that
this person whoever it is making the
threats was watching here but another
little moment that is important is lars
we see has this cell phone that's
battery doesn't die i guess it's in the
woods and it's a person checking in on
him whatever someone from his journalist
team but you can tell he's like it's
going you know oh she's doubting us like
saying that whatever their mission was
for masha and this resort he's making it
like he's still on board but he's
clearly been converted we know this now
and this confirms that the way he says
it so again just great delivery by luke
evans here it's also a
strange scene with yao and delilah here
because of what masha's doing it's like
everybody's episode is getting closer
and bonds are being fixed now and
there's just this you know odd sexual
encounter between yao and delilah where
they're they're doing sexually changed
without touching like they're just
waving fingers this is like okay and
then masha gets a text from this person
threatening her saying you're next and
it's like under a picture it seems like
a dead animal maybe someone can clarify
what's actually in that photo and then
just touching base again with people
getting closer because of this heavier
dosage and now you see jessica and ben
are full molly now just like yao said
that the molly was going to bring
relationships closer and you see
jessica's getting what she wants this
whole time that ben's being attentive to
her ben's being emotionally available to
her and he's loving to her and bring up
when they first fell in love this is
like all she ever wanted so that's why
i'm saying i hope we get payoff for all
this because it feels like this is just
the episode making it seem like wow you
know masha's plan does work everyone's
happy on all these drugs and look what
it's doing but i feel like we're gonna
get the consequence of all this next
episode so i hope it goes that way so we
feel like we sat through all this and it
was worth it now again my favorite scene
in this episode like last week is
another tony and francis scene there is
something about the chemistry between
miss mccarthy and bobby cannavale that
is impeccable and what i mean by that is
also that they bring the best out in
each other it's kind of magic on screen
with them and that just happens by
chance too like you can never just plan
that and they got lightning in a bottle
with these two together so the more with
them together on camera the better and
man like i thought this was so powerful
and heavy because he's like he wasn't
there when either of his kids were born
tony so it's going back to why he was
triggered by lars dream and one reason
was because of football he said the
other was because of drugs is why he
didn't see his kids and tony tells
francis she's a good person and you know
the best line and heartbreaking line and
dark is when he says i'm not sure i want
any of this bad enough francis i'm not
gonna make it maybe to the end of the
weekend of the year this scares francis
it's heart-wrenching and we feel as
francis in the scene about tony so again
what i was talking about last week is
like it's not just characters that make
shows great it's relationships and this
relationship is just just crushing you
feel so close to these two now and
what's happening with tony and again it
feels like we're in the kind of the seat
of francis and it's it's hard to watch
but it's it's really getting emotional
payoff here for sure and like i'm saying
that if we're going emmys here bobby
kind of volley and michael shannon
clearly front rudders but that other
third person that's also a front-runner
is clearly regina hall with this like
amazing performance she's doing
dramatically again i just know her
mostly from scary movie films but this
has blown me away and this really shows
i think her emmy submission scene should
be when she sees lars here she's getting
jealous she's talking to herself after
getting triggered by seeing jessica and
ben having this molly hot tub sex and
lars shows his good side again great
acting by luke evans as well but just
seeing carmel here just freaking out it
felt so real by regina hall like i was
so impressed by this like fully immersed
in this character and he's saying how
you know meet someone new you know
you're a vibrant woman so it's coming
full circle because again remember
carmel lunged at lars not too long ago
so i really like this and just her
facing her not over her ex-husband but
again you're just remembering you're
like wow lars who's the biggest jerk of
them all is like the nicest episode but
you wonder like is it just because of
this extra high dosage that everyone's
so kind so it's interesting and it makes
you question just like how far can we go
with drugs and what's masha's endgame
here and is it right is it wrong it's
fascinating stuff to be honest but this
last scene we see zoe gets her speech
about her brother here but saying that
everyone here feels like family so it's
coming all around where they're all
fighting in the beginning and it's just
making think about them all on drugs is
that the only reason or do they really
bond and you know she's getting her due
finally gracie and patton and this mog
she just does amazing here and this
whole cast honestly i could just praise
everybody it's an all-star cast you know
and she's saying though people are
treating like a person here that she
likes not a victim not a patient and
what is interesting is that masha sees
zoe see her brother again hallucination
here and she says in russian to her
you're the key so again zoe doesn't know
what the hell she's saying it's in
russian and we're wondering what masha
means by that so that's gonna be
interesting it's a nice little
cliffhanger in itself but we see
napoleon start singing again i just have
this feeling and i'm scared that every
time something like this happens that
napoleon's just gonna collapse or
something because i feel like we've kind
of wrapped his story so i'm worried
because he's such a great character but
he survives and we see all the close
pairs and steps are dancing so it's a
nice little mini bow in this episode so
for me it's a solid episode i think it's
one again you should watch twice to
really appreciate it it's slow character
focused so again as its own i'm giving
it a strong score i would give it an 8.8
but it could be something i get mad at
and it would bring the score down if it
doesn't pay off next episode like
because it focused solely on that goal
of relationship building and character
building but not moving the plot really
that much forward at all and not making
enough interest in the plot i hope that
the next episode like last week's is
plot heavy and we get payoff in that
something's going to give here that
there's going to be consequences for our
character and i was just happy which i
imagine will be but as of right now i
really like this episode so i just hope
we get a payoff for it that's with like
an asterix basically so let me know what
you guys thought of it down below i'd
love to hear your thoughts i read every
comment i try to respond as many as i
can again please just subscribe it helps
me in so many ways you have no idea i
appreciate all of you and if you really
love what i do here you can become a
member support me and you'll get perks
like live streams badges and yeah it
would just you know help me do my dream
one day of doing this full time and be
able to make more reviews for you guys
and interviews so appreciate all of you
and please follow me at stevenshow on
twitter instagram and tick tock now for
more of me and i'll see you next time